I feel very honored to be able to be the
one to show you you can see this your
reaction that's my face Wow thank you
what does this all mean to you I mean
it's incredibly validating I think it's
dangerously validating no it's nice it
was a good little shoot I'm honored to
be on the same cover it's too fun that's
really that wanting to ask you this for
years now okay
the friends anniversary is coming up is
it yes yeah you know this no okay well
do you feel like Ben should have a
spinoff no come on
why not maybe like 20 like mid-20s by
now I'm a purist I think I think friends
sits in this perfect little bubble of
golden nostalgia and I think it's I
think it's dangerous to re-enter into
any of those properties and decide like
what can we do to commodify this so I
think you know I think it should stay
the way it was we stay beautiful and
exist the way it was it's that same way
that people have really enjoyed it for
so many years and I don't know I think
it would also be incredibly vain for me
to be here to be like yeah dude I need
my own spin-off man well I appreciate
having the vote of confidence
happy belated birthday how'd you
celebrate
I was actually on a bachelor party in
New Orleans that's kind of fun I guess
I've reached an age where I have seven
friends getting married this year so
it's about carving time out
and going to as many bachelor parties as
possible and celebrating love and
celebrating love how annoyed were you by
all those rumors incredibly I don't care
I mean that's the nature of our industry
you had fun with it I feel like yeah I
think you have to poke fun it a little
bit I think it's kind of something you
sign up for a little bit but yeah as
long as you can keep it fun and light
it's all good
I know Lily wrote you really nice column
her birthday's coming up next month
how will you top the poem oh I'm not I'm
not a poet I do not write I'll figure
out some something beautiful thank you
so much have fun tonight
[Music]